World War II is about to break out and
everybody wants to know where should
they store their money should you put it
in Gold should you put it in cash US
dollars or even Bitcoin I'm hearing that
people don't think Bitcoin is a good
idea but I actually disagree and I think
Bitcoin is the best place to store your
money in the case of World War III and
here is why we saw Bitcoin survive
lockdowns supply chain holes
unprecedented money printing
unprecedented inflation Wars riots but
it didn't just survive it Bitcoin is
actually up nearly 700% since all of
this started so it's an asset that's
proven itself but not only that you need
an asset which is reliable an asset
which is decentralized in times of War
so it cannot be shut down by any
jurisdictions that is why Bitcoin is one
of the best places to store your money
in the case of World War II